foreign
nope nope nope
she's like you were a kid
you're like an infant child they're
reaching into a cookie jar and I was
like nope
oh boy
oh my God yeah it made me laugh hey
everybody we're a little tired sorry hey
that was super funny
that was funny
hey everybody he was going to click a
button that would remove us from the
screen and I kept saying no like nope
nope nope nope and he kept like going
towards it I go no no you want to go up
there to the live button instead of
remove because they're two way different
things anyways what's going on everybody
we are here in Tampa Florida
um two shows tonight two shows tomorrow
we're psyched to be here uh we are going
to be answering questions today
um that's what we uh
that's what we've decided we're going to
do with this stream
um so list them up here we're going to
try to write them down and get to them
if you um
if you have done this for this before
you know that I fall behind on questions
comments but I'm gonna do my best not to
you just gotta keep scrolling like if
you missed questions you miss questions
you just have to let the chat go
huh you scroll up to look for questions
you just gotta let the chat go you gotta
let the track go and just read and stop
no no no that's what I'm saying but I'd
like to put some on the screen right no
that I that's fine but you just have to
go with what's present in the chat
because now you already have 15 new
comments and you have to catch up
all right but I just want to get this
Association I want to acknowledge
something
absolutely thank you
any advice for upcoming for aspiring
comedians
um yeah go ahead get on stage yeah
that's that's what he's gonna tell you
that's the only advice there is only
reason the only way you're going to be
able to tell whether or not you want to
do it more than once is going on stage
yeah that's it if you ask any comic that
knows anything about comedy they're not
going to be like hey sit down and write
out your first
hour of material is going to eat digs so
just get on stage and learn how to learn
how to do what you like to do up there
figuring out who you are on stage how do
you prepare to go on
my stretch honestly people come and see
me in Green Room all the time like we'll
give you your time I'm like I don't
I could be in the middle of a party
in a swimming pool
if you're like hey you get two minutes
I'll just get out of the pool and get on
stage it's such an extension of just um
what I who I am really that it doesn't
feel much different I do some stretching
to get my blood flowing that's what I do
I used to do that I used to smoke three
cigarettes before I went outside
you see how far behind you already it's
all right we'll catch up any Dallas days
coming up Fort Worth in October my
friend somebody said Idaho Falls I think
anytime we go to Idaho we only go to
Boise and I think Idaho Falls is Twin
Falls and Twin Falls is uh gorgeous I
love it there it's amazing dude this is
something that even me with limited
knowledge polar bear
polar bears
which Bearer wanted to fight I thought
he asked which bear would you beat in a
fight polymer
would you beat me if I say which bear
would win in a fight yeah
yeah I don't know man grizzly bear it
said polar brown or black oh Grizzly
wasn't in there oh yeah yeah you put a
grizzly bear in there
polar bear I might go Grizzly maybe but
I'd go polar I I know when you will be
in Iowa in two weeks in Des Moines Des
Moines
um all right so and guys comedian Josh
wolf.com for tour dates so I don't want
to spend too much time talking about
where I'm coming to
um Community joshua.com for tour dates I
got so many places coming up we both do
UK and Europe that tour is about to be
announced but that starts in October and
goes through November
um so okay
here we go you want to pick
sure okay I'm just you can keep
scrolling I'll read faster
I just can't see oh yeah
I will answer that one this one uh okay
and you picked it
yeah I'll answer that
uh 15.
foreign
I think I was 16 going on 17. yeah you I
remember you told me about it actually
you asked well and then you told me well
yeah because you asked well most kids
just people like do you remember what
the interaction was because I remember
it very vividly no no no we were in the
car yeah
dump it
yo what the hell that's Florida man it
did just start dumb it was sunny and now
it's like
pissing rain yeah how I don't I don't
remember the interaction I don't care so
we were in the car we were driving we
were driving somewhere I don't know
where you guys were just been out of
thank you kellyanne you guys just been
out of town for the weekend
um and we were driving somewhere
and uh
we were just sitting in the car and you
you you asked the question so randomly
and you legit just asked did you did you
uh did you lose your virginity this week
and I said yes and you went all right
nice and you fist bumped me and then we
sat in silence for the next 10 minutes
it's pretty great makes me laugh when I
think about it no it is a pissy green
now what the hell we just frizz pumped
yeah you you were driving and you stuck
your hand I didn't even look him he's
like so words I say I'm driving we're
flipped right I'm in the driver's seat
and you ask me that and you're like all
right cool nice stuck a fist out a fist
bump and then you just kept drowning we
didn't talk for like another 10 minutes
that's amazing yeah that's amazing this
is old school new school for sure
Allison all right let me scroll down a
little bit I'm sorry yeah a lot of
yourself
um take a few bong ribs we're not it's
not how we're doing it right I would if
I could yeah comedian Josh Wolf to uh uh
uh
comedian joshua.com for tour dates and
tickets if you go and look at your tour
date there should be a link to go buy
tickets yeah at an affordable price uh
I've never slept with a current clown
drewby Drew says polar bear would
dominate any bear
yeah Grizzly I just don't know I'm not
educated brown bear is a grizzly
grizzly bear they're different who would
win a fight Segura or bird if you're
talking about those Bears listen
I think if the fight is in the first
round I'm going Bert
but if there's stamina involved I'm
going Tom yeah that's fair I think
however if there's alcohol involved I'm
then again going Burger
um
I don't know why you keep typing clown
dude but I don't have ever slept with a
clown I mean this is the stupidest
question ever but I'm hoping by
acknowledging you you'll shut the
up yeah but you know how well that works
um have I ever been around livestock
yeah
like on a farm
yeah yeah Jacob saw a camel the other
day in Vegas that was weird
um yeah that was a bananas crazy uh
polar bear hair is not actually white
that is what
uh it's something about like being like
the light reflecting or something like
that they're gonna pull some beside
okay I didn't
who ordered the porn we just uh released
that yeah
um did you say you lost his genitals or
he lost his virginity
um I'm pretty sure I said Virginia both
of us said virginity
I thank you for the donations I
appreciate it very much Mike
um thank you so much you know
you have to oh that's okay sorry that's
yeah I usually do on stream and thank
you CW Arts I appreciate it thank you so
much yes you know they can see it too I
know okay cool I'll just I'm just I
don't know yeah cool I don't
I'm not ignite yeah yeah yep sure
um thanks Gina I appreciate it I wish I
could come to your show me too
um will you please touch the camera my
camera through the fence
I don't know what that means
yeah that's how I touch the camera I
don't know if that's what you wanted
that's what I'm doing how do you think
you'd have reacted if he had been your
daughter like if he had been my daughter
me me like I think it's about the
virginity question is what they asked
you know if I was your daughter instead
of yourself how would you have reacted
to the answer to that question oh I'm
not probably a fist bump also sex
shaming anybody this is you know I I
know what my preference is but like
it's your life man and I was a teenager
I knew that strict parents made sneaky
kids and so I just want my kids to be
open with me
so I listen
do you think I'm dumb enough to think my
daughter's gonna be a virgin until she
gets married well you know what's crazy
on that note there's you know what I
mean so like I I didn't really have a
double standard you know what's a weird
crazy thing on that note that's kind of
related when I really you know T.I
goes with his daughter every year or
after every gynecologist appointment to
make sure that she's still a virgin
before marriage he goes to every single
appointment with her yeah I'm not that's
not me but how nuts is that how crazy is
that she's like 27 yeah that's not my
thing
how many this is a great question Lori
how many times a day do you guys talk
about buttholes you know what
some days none some days too much
I'll tell you I will take the blame for
the too much part of that because I feel
like nobody else can blame on you
you're the only person I'd be blaming
for that well what if it was you who did
all the butthole talks but it's not
yeah and to be fair it's just like
anyways
yeah coach
this is interesting I have one instacart
deliver one that puts her feet in The
Pick of my food order how much should I
tip
um zero because her feet is near her
feet are near your food I'm not a feed
dude but I know a lot of people are but
like honestly
I if I
couldn't pick Beth's feet out of a
lineup same
I like for her mind like I couldn't I
wouldn't be able to pick my girlfriend I
couldn't pick her but then again also my
girlfriend hates her feet so much that
she doesn't even like to look at her own
feet so she wears socks all the time
yeah I couldn't pick your mom's feed and
she walked around Barefoot I think I
could pick my feet out of the lineup I
could pick my feet because I have my
because of my hammer toe I can pick my
feet on the lineup because my up
Doritos oh that's right because you're
yeah that's right it's pretty accurate
actually yeah I think that's the sound
they would make too if they ever like
they ever had a sound effect coming out
of the shoe
yeah yeah
um
they'd be like sloth from
work from uh Goonies we're coming to hey
that's hilarious
[Laughter]
grizzly bears are brown but they're not
brown bear thank you
there's a difference between brown bear
and a grizzly bear
trust me thank you Mike
guys
check the comedian joshua.com
um yeah yeah what does this say I can't
hear you uh tell us the time your boy
made you so mad you cannot talk unless
you stutter and later you found out you
were wrong well I'm not wrong ever
what
have I ever apologized to you for a
punishment or for flying off the handle
I know I've apologized to you for
snapping at you before you definitely
apologize for snapping
if I what happened pretty recently I'm
not gonna lie when was that I don't know
she said we were on the road or like
technology was making you angry or you
were hungry oh I know what it was man
you know old man no you know I know
what it was
and I I didn't snap I just wasn't
what was it I've been trying to give you
he opens for me now oh that's what it
was yeah yeah he opens for me now and he
had a really good set
and I've I've been trying to get him to
do this one specific thing
in the set and I've been telling him
about it for a couple months a couple
months he just hasn't been doing it and
he had a great set and he came in after
his set and the feature was on stage and
he said to me yo that was a great set I
really felt really good about it yeah
yeah and I said good man I said why and
then I went right into why aren't you
doing
what I asked you to do yeah and then I
he texted me almost immediately yeah I
was I was out watching our feature set
Lee sayat and uh
he texted me almost right away and he
was like didn't mean to try and on
your parade and I was like look man you
could say all you wanted I know my set
was good and nobody can take that from
me and it's fine because he's just
trying to help yeah but I my I was
I should have not reacted with that
because I should have lived in the happy
moment with you and then just addressed
it later but there's
it was such a wow
not really because you just want me to
be
you've always just wanted me to be
better even though I'm good at what I
want to do but so here's the thing like
the one thing I will say to it is like
it's okay to come with a constructive
criticism but for me follow it with a
compliment yeah or or 100 or all the way
around be like yo that was a really good
set love this this and this but you
still need to do this 100 makes sense
yeah and what I what I should what I
should have done
is the mistake here's the other mistake
dude and this is the bigger mistake the
bigger mistake is that
I'm not allowing us to live in the
moment and the moment is amazing the
moment is a great set for you and I'm
immediately dismissing the moment for
the future and you can't do that you
know what I'm saying so so
yeah I I but here's the thing man you're
constantly I'm always evolving and
becoming a different person and I'm not
far from being human yeah can you please
open your Wikipedia again so Jacob can
mess with it hey I want you guys to know
right now
I've we have made as a collective I mean
me and everybody else because apparently
everybody else figured it out you I'm
locked out nobody can make the edits did
you see the the what somebody put on
your mom's Wikipedia page yeah
Jacob wolf starred in the snuff porn
film no directed directed directed the
stuff porn film anal party free people
are starting to go to Wicked my wife's
Wikipedia page hilarious it made me
laugh yeah that's pretty good um what is
that
it say okay
um so what's the weirdest story you
haven't told on stage well I want to
tell you something if I haven't told it
on stage it's not weird enough no it
means I'm not telling anybody
yeah yeah do you know what I mean what
are you gonna do
did you post that Rhino clip already
yeah I posted it what are you gonna do
it it's such a good story
um yeah maybe I'll do it this weekend
hey we're gonna be in the UK in October
yeah yeah yeah what he said tell me the
first time you were really high
I can tell you the first time I was
really high
I'll let you think about it I know mine
yo I've been smoking weed for a long
time
so I was 21. and look man I had lived in
Massachusetts
and God was going to school in Texas and
so the weed was meh you know listen
here's the generation of weed I came
from it didn't have names it was just
called weed
and it had seeds and it looked brownish
or smelled like oregano and but I was
not in high school on the East Coast at
that time getting good weed no same with
Texas it was just dirt I was getting
good ecstasy in Texas I bet you're
probably in a lot of good parts in Texas
that weren't well the Ecstasy was like
y'all ready for this
um
did I throw you happy yeah anyways
so I get to California this is the first
I was there trying La out for a year I
took a year off from college I went to
California
and our next door neighbor at apartment
I was rooming with my cousin Scott wolf
and some of you may know my buddy Neil
cooler and this dude who played
classical guitar
I never seen anyone play the 12th string
like you know
yeah right with
um
like a soft not linen but real soft
strings and so
I had never had California weed before
and so we're sitting on this couch
in my and it was me this kid and I
remember his name Scott and Neo and um I
was like yeah I'm a weed smoker he was
like well this is good weed I'm like I'm
a good read before
yo I he looked at me at one point like
I'd slow down
and I was just puffing away because we I
was like on a behind before we go out
and he was like this is one hit weed oh
I've heard that before
I they left
me on the couch you could move now
and when they came back you were still
in the same spot yeah
yeah I've had one of those I feel like
the first time can I can I say you know
how I was high when they came back my
hands I was sitting like this my hands
on my oh I know I know which one is on
my legs and when they came home I was
like oh hey and I moved my hands and
there was sweat stains both hands I love
that on my pants I think the first time
I was like really really high
yo no joke Martin when I stole your
edible dude you were oh I was
up
it might be that dude you either you
were like I was I was hot so you
you ever get to a point where you're so
high where you you just lose all your
clothes like I was at a point where I
was laying in bed just in my underwear
and it was like it was like 75 or 80
degrees out like it wasn't even have you
ever that time in um
the sweaty I think happens edible more
than it does smoking
yeah it's for me nowadays it's really
hard for me to get like a high high off
smoking that time in California was the
first time I'd ever smoked myself death
do you know when your ears go you're
like
oh yeah smoke yourself but I think the
first time also like because smoking for
me doesn't I could only get a certain
high now when I smoke weed the only way
for me to go above that is either do
psychedelics or do Edibles
um but there was there was that time I
got an edible from a dealer and he said
it was on and it said 100 milligrams but
it was a thousand yeah and it was
missing a zero yeah I'm really sick
after that but I was oh super high after
I threw up holy crap
everybody I see the towns and cities and
countries you want me to come to I'm
coming to A lot of them comedian
joshua.com for 20 seconds but the UK
questions man October okay
um
did you ever yell at Jacob when he was
11 year old kid probably
I remember taking them off a baseball
field and putting them in our car I was
before 11 though yeah
or two of them yeah I was 11 years old
yeah he was throwing a bit of a fit on
the feet it took me off the mound when I
wanted one more app it's all I wanted I
just want to finish the batter I wanted
to get out of the inning he started to
throw a little fit and I was like hey
you went to sit on the bench
yeah
we don't see in the summer heat in a
black minivan I go get in the car
for my teammates and I was like no
you're not not like that yeah
we won them we did win we did win we
also won a championship with that team
that was the Angels would I ever let us
let AI write a song for you no no
I I like writing I like creating I like
all that
strict care parents make sneaky kids
like me is that how far behind me are
bro I watch watch it's gonna reload now
watch watch how far up you are oh my God
okay I'm getting there everybody
uh what's going on Jake how are you not
a question statement but Jacob your
girlfriend is gorgeous she is oh yes she
is I appreciate that yeah
this one right here oh what happened
yeah what happens in my meet and greets
we meet and we greet that's about it man
now listen and remember when you're
coming to my shows Friday night late
shows are my mushroom shows and Saturday
night lady gives away a guitar I give
away my guitar so
um thank you Suzanne I appreciate it
very much
uh thank you very much for the
compliments are super nice I appreciate
it
what city is your favorite coming to
perform in the United States and what
country is your favorite to perform
hey Ross how you doing dude
oh hey man
um I
sitting in the states is so I my cut the
country okay it's tough to I've only
performed internationally once this is
so what country do I like to visit the
most which where did I like to perform
the most perform he says performance so
Brisbane
Australia was pretty amazing
yeah that's pretty outstanding I loved
it hard to say man I really love this
country of New Zealand and Australia
both both pretty special yeah I think
those Australian crabs but the the tour
this year we're going to Amsterdam and
Oslo and Copenhagen so we're pretty
excited we'll tell you as far as the
states
it varies it changes all the time yeah
yeah yeah uh we love Boston of course
um
what else going on you know I love that
Mall of America I love Minnesota oh yeah
we never leave the yeah we don't have to
go anywhere yeah awesome I'm gonna get
high on a Friday and walk around that
empty mall that's gonna be weird
hey thank you very much that'll be a
good time I told you last time what I
want to do is let me get high and walk
around the empty Mall of America after
hours yeah then go climb on the roller
coaster you know yeah I'll do that thank
you guys I won't climb on a roller
coaster I will
all right let me see what else
thank you about the Rhino story
um okay
all right all right I'm just trying to
you know what I mean no New Orleans
dates there's no Comedy Club in Newark
that's right actually you know what I'm
funny somebody DM me said they did just
open a comedy club in New Orleans so
look if they wanna if they want to book
Joshua book Joshua but there are no
comedy clubs in Newark was I open about
smoking pot with my kids when they were
younger no
when I when I was like 16 but then again
I asked yeah well I didn't ask but also
like
he has the internet
I was doing a show called The High Life
so so
I I never smoked in front of them or
well I was high in front of him until I
realized that they knew I was high and
then I was like I gotta stop getting
high in front of them yep
um
you should
Sing the lyrics how do you handle temper
tantrums oh
my dad used to say if you like so my
brother one time we were all in a
grocery store and my brother who's the
oldest had a little bit of a fit and my
dad said if you don't calm down it's not
doing a fit I'm Gonna Leave You here and
Trevor wouldn't stop so my dad picked up
my sister and I and left the store well
to be fair I gave him a warning I was
like hey man we're leaving and also he
didn't actually leave he just sat in the
car in the parking lot not sure no no
I was trying to help you out did you
actually I wouldn't drive home I'm not
leaving him but I drove out of the
parking lot so he could see me and then
I just drove back around
but yeah guess what Trevor never did
after that
no yo man guess what also you're the
parent you're the kid yeah like you they
can have a temperature all they want
guess who still holds all the power are
you and if you don't think that and
you've already lost the battle take it
easy dude I'm just saying I mean you're
not a parent it's sometimes it's hard
right but I take it from you you were
the parent yeah I know but like I didn't
my here's the thing
I didn't mind
the because I look I'm not scared I
never parented scared like you remember
you were 12 years old and
um
and you and a friend of yours wanted to
go to Beaman Park and I was like just
hop on your bikes and go and he was like
I gotta call my mom and see if she'll
let me go to the park by myself yeah and
I was like you're almost 13 years old
yeah yeah that was not so I didn't
parents scared you know I'm sorry I'm
not gonna lie there are two hairs coming
out of your face that I want to pull so
bad get one see what happens
ah don't get the other one I didn't even
get that one you didn't oh I'm back
no that is rude it's deep in there oh it
is they're just sticking out in one spot
and they're for some reason darker than
the rest of them I
I don't okay you can get one just one I
need to figure out which one holy crap
which one I can grab why did you guys
take your skip that one because I try
and I missed how did you miss
just get it no you see trying to grab
more than one
[Laughter]
no come on
yeah those ones are those ones are in
there dog you almost pulled a tooth out
I know oh this one is attached to a
tooth I think
okay one last try one last try
hey from bigger
ah oh I got those ones damn it a couple
three but two
oh those are
that's what I'm saying bro why is that
half of it's a different color that's
why I was gonna that's how deep it was
they were it was staring me if it you
guys could probably see there were a
couple times where I was I was like it's
like that scene from Austin Powers where
I was like I wanted to get it so bad
yeah you're allowed to bring gifts there
you go
hmm
good Lord there's still a little one
there but I'll leave it don't with
me
hey Vegas you know I performed there
every Monday night at Kimmel's Comedy
Club starting in August it'll be at 7 30
every Monday night facts ever gotten too
high for a show
I did in Portland once we did I did acid
during the day and was still super high
by the time the show started yeah I
don't think so
um
I don't think so I'm still professional
he's very professional yeah yeah I I um
Jacob's 26.
uh okay
are you kidding me yeah that one
probably didn't feel great
no oh I brought one next while you're
sleeping don't you I think while you're
sleeping I'm gonna just I'm gonna film
myself pulling it for Mom
what band would I like to collaborate
with past or present on stage
well I'll tell you something I've had
the distinct pleasure to collaborate on
stage with jelly roll with
um Jewel with Chris Kirkpatrick with the
guys from Little Big Town
[Music]
um
Taylor Lynn
so for me it would have to be somebody
that I would want to do a parody with
uh Brook Eden was amazing waiting for
you and Zach yeah you know what
I've been buddies was that for a little
bit I would love to do a song with Zach
because Zach is a really funny dude I
would say Zac Brown because I know he
would be really good at also writing
right writing a song you can think of
words yeah these two and super things
that you wouldn't do yeah
um hey man oh yeah everybody go check
out our podcast hey man
all right you are almost caught up
you're caught up I'm caught up
you're officially caught up holy
not even in the top
zero and and not that any disrespect to
Weird Al but we come at those songs
differently he's making a true parody
Yeah clean no punch lines
yeah it's if they're fun videos to watch
but like hello
hello Caitlyn that's my daughter
everybody what's up
we did collaborate with this uh a song
on stage
um
you're in Orlando next month that's
right indeed we are in Orlando next week
I would love to do hot ones we're gonna
make it happen yes oh my God yeah you
need to make that happen Jacob will be
in Jacksonville in August I will be in
Jacksonville yeah Orlando Orlando and
Jacksonville in August
maybe they might be the same week
we might do Thursday Friday Saturday I'm
not sure what the plan is
um Everybody meet and greets happen at
every show
yeah meet and greets are free for
anybody who wants to wait in line yeah I
don't we don't charge for me yeah I
don't um I don't charge we're in Texas
in October comedian Josh wolf.com for
tour dates
um
comedy clubs reach out to me right now
Ross
all right
what's a memory
we wish I wish we could relive again
David Ortiz
that was a good time the whole weekend
monster seats watching his number get
retired sitting in a box the roast
we went and saw a Socks game we met the
police officer that was in the bullpen
when Tori Hunter got sent over the wall
I met Bill Burr yeah uh Anthony Mackey
Gronk Pedroia it was a crazy weekend oh
no there's uh
yeah that for me I think the weirdest
thing I've seen Matt ever or the show I
want to say at a meet and greet we saw
somebody take a spider out of his pants
in Australia yeah that was a little
weird yeah
um
we're doing the UK in October Danny
I would say
um
because just like the whole the whole
four days five days was
outstanding it was also where I really
got to know Adam Ray yeah so that was
fun I don't know man for me it would be
more it would probably be
something where like a sports moment
like younger no something where we were
all together me you your brother your
sister and your mom what about uh your
50th in Arizona
that's the most recently video plus
Grandma and Grandpa over there yeah
probably that something like that that's
something where we were all together it
feels like something that I was like
recent yeah it didn't have to be reason
but something like that
um
okay what time is it true we guys listen
thank you very much
um over to Tampa thanks Amanda
yeah listen guys so
what was I gonna say oh the hey man
podcast
Jacob will be at every date except for
Omaha and Fort Worth which are back back
weeks which is the last weekend in
September and the first week in October
I have seen I have some pre uh
obligations prior to that Caitlyn is
extremely funny true true that like
extremely funny always been extremely
extremely funny
uh and super creative also well all of
them are she's but she's extremely funny
um what's my shirt with the cat cake
do you want a pew pew shirt
she definitely
um this is hilarious what she wrote
ah who your sister
oh funnier all I saw was funnier and I
didn't know what it was pertaining to
all right everybody look
uh
well he doesn't drink
I will say the last time I saw him drink
even like more than one drink we were in
Cabo when I was 16.
I was kind of drunk kinda kinda do you
remember what you said
you said I was sitting in a Cabana on
the beach okay and
I was just chilling we had a hookah set
up like I was vibing you know like I was
having a good time chilling out and then
all of a sudden this dude comes
stumbling through the sand
to the Cabana and leans in he's like hey
I was like
there's what's that I was like it's
hookah he goes as a weed I was like no
no it's hookah he goes what is it weed I
was like no no you didn't just hear what
I said I go it's tobacco he goes can I
hit it I go he goes am I going to like
it I go is he gonna give you a head rush
I go but do not smoke this like you
would smoke weed hit it and blow it
right back out like you're not supposed
to like inhale it it's gonna really
you up and what did he do not listen and
what did he do inhaler and what happened
after he coughed his head up for about
five straight minutes and then tried to
hit it again and do it differently he
did it the same way I don't know how to
hit it and then what and then and I was
like you good you wouldn't yeah I'd go
do you have a drink or two at the bar he
goes yeah
I might uh I might have gotten five or
six double Tequilas on the rocks and
drank them all in about 15 minutes and I
was like Jesus we was a that was the
last time I ever saw him like that might
be the last time I ever saw you drink no
no no we took a shot in Cleveland when I
was 18 when I came to visit you on that
on so we might have taken a shot in
Nashville once or twice
you have now with me this is not an on
the animals okay
that's what it was called that's right
thanks Kate we were trying to remember
the name of that place the other day on
the animals is what it was called that's
right
all right you want a pew pew shirt I
will post what does it say dude it says
where it's from back here
Reagan raygun
is it raygun.com
yeah what is my gym routine
he drinks he drinks some electrolytes
before he heads to the gym with a cup of
coffee and then he'll get to the gym and
he'll walk in scan put his headphones on
and then pick somebody to be mad at in
the gym so he'll literally walk in and
say I was wearing because I'm wearing
pink shorts right now say I was wearing
them in the gym he would come in and
look at me and go man I hate that dude's
shorts and then he would work
out using the anger just in case I need
motivation using the fake anger in his
mind about how much he hates my shorts
I'm like Michael Jordan I gotta generate
but it works yeah he uh he works out he
works aggressive's not the right word
and angry he's not the right word
anymore he works out
um
I guess aggressive is actually good
again I listen I I
whatever addictive
parts of my personality I try to really
sink into
health
and gym because I know if I sink it into
something else it's not gonna be great
the rain's gone I don't know but it'll
be back it's Florida
um so I I'm a little psychotic I when
I'm home I work out if you count the
three mile hike in the morning I work
out twice a day so I'll do the three
mile hike at like five in the morning
and then I work out you know what I lift
at home I lift blunts yo dude down from
mouth and back yeah straight the Pilates
class is the best and I want to tell you
something else my booty looks
real good no my biggest fear is having
your ass not look good my biggest fear
is old man ass well it's gonna happen
eventually that you know when old
dudes get that completely flat ass yeah
well it looks like they have a lot of
in their pants but it's literally
just their butt but it also sags down
from right that's what I'm saying it
looks like they themselves but it's
just their ass no but like somehow their
belt still is at their waist but their
back pocket is somewhere around the back
of their knee yeah like it doesn't make
a whole lot of sense this makes me laugh
what does it say I did a Sean here nude
but with my junk painted green for the
green screen
I think it's a great idea it makes me
laugh yeah
um
oh so many all my kids so many
so so so so so so many yeah I remember
that
um
your
[Music]
um Caitlyn trapped you under a um
uh laundry basket and sat on it that's
pretty funny yeah but had you convinced
that it was fun
yeah it's like that game mouse trap well
no it was funny she was like it's fun
right and you're like no and you're like
she was like yeah it is so you thought
it was a lot of fun
and um
it was really it was a Jedi mind trick
she pulled on here's what she did yeah
hold on
I'm bummed you didn't mention a lot of
my jokes cat if you see the way this
Scrolls
I we see some we don't see others I
haven't that's the first time I've even
seen your name but yeah please take your
feelings off of the
because they're we can't you know what I
mean take your feelings and your jokes
elsewhere you know
but take your feelings out of it because
we can't we can't we can't see him yeah
uh best advice for starting out okay we
know that one get on stage all right
everybody
uh we
uh
oh oh that's the same incident Okay
click that one Jessica okay so she asked
Joe which happened first Jacob getting
grounded all summer for stealing Josh's
weed or the high dose edible he took
that is why I got grounded because that
is the edible I took
so same incident I took the animal first
got grounded after
yes that's what happened yeah yeah
um my favorite edible I like an absolute
extract is it just a tiny little Hill it
looks like a fish oil pill yeah
why don't I read questions
uh what's going on European wolves
uh is that a Playboy Bunny Tattoo
yes
okay here's a good one Jacob what is
your favorite thing about doing comedy
shows with your dad
um I think my favorite thing right now
is really just uh the change of pace in
my life uh and change of Direction like
I think for the first time in a really
long time like or maybe first time ever
um I'm like driven in my career and in
what I'm doing and excited about the
future when in the past when I was
working TV production I was just I
couldn't wait for every day to be over
do you know what he said that to me the
other day
what was really exciting for me Isn't
that it's what I do for a living or
anything like that but I want
I think it's so important to live with
purpose
it gives like you feel different waking
up every day and getting through your
day
I think purpose is so important and so I
want all my kids to find whatever their
purposes
and so if he has purpose now whatever it
is I'm psyched for that yeah you know
what I mean
um cat I saw your joke
uh
yep
yeah we'll leave it at that yeah uh
who's the better dancer
have you guys ever seen me do the
running man we don't have to do it now
you're gonna pull a muscle
um it's
can we do a podcast highlight while
skydiving
yo if you set all that up I'm in
but also how are you gonna podcast while
skydiving of course I'm still farting on
Plants I do too
I farted a couple times during this
podcast I farted on the radio show this
morning did you smell it no yeah bad oh
yeah I didn't sell that one my God I was
really hoping
it would get out in the studio because I
wanted to see if they were going to talk
about it
it almost did anyways it's a bummer
as someone with an aging man
you know what that means she probably
was a comment from before that she was
um listen
I'm not saying he will be there but I'm
not saying he won't don't don't don't
finish that sentence
so you're not saying anything up that's
true
um
okay everybody we're gonna go
um I'm gonna take a nap
um
Caitlin ash oh I can answer this and
then I gotta go do you know the correct
answer yeah I do know the answer he says
if he was a new comedy he wanted to be a
teacher 100
I absolutely
love watching people get it come to
Colombia yeah I love watching people
get it
you know what I mean like when you're
teaching him something that's why I
loved coaching his baseball teams
um
I doubt it probably not and I'm gonna
tell you why because
he doesn't repeat jokes
as funny as they are but he's already
done it and he did it the best possible
way the first time so not only that
somebody said this final go on Pizza no
it's a sin not only that but nobody's
let me throw their bachelor party zero
people
you know who's you know who's not even
inviting him to his
me
I would love to be a coach
yeah I feel more than a teacher but I
would
teaching something that teaches
something like history I think would be
for me because I think
there's a way to make everything fun
and you can make it boring or you can
make it fun true and I would say the
same thing with parenting sure so I I
would do something that I could try to
make fun but I know I could make history
fun Jacob do you ever feel like Greta
thundberg screaming you've stolen my
childhood
do I ever feel like Greta like like I
stole your childhood no
if anything he gave me a ridiculously
cool topic Amanda hello to your son land
I landed
um all right everybody hey Caitlin
Ashley
text him for the people shirt yeah uh if
you want a PPU go on the website and
just send me the link to which one you
want and I'll get it for you and send it
out yep okay
thanks Boyer and Casey and
and Caitlin Ash I love you
comedian joshua.com for tourism tickets
because I still see people asking
questions comedian joshua.com for tour
dates and tickets the UK will be
announced soon we were just in Australia
in January hopefully probably again this
next year
um and if you don't see uh uh your City
on there you will soon we will be in a
city near you
shortly we promise we promise we promise
um Tampa two tonight two tomorrow
that's it that's all I got
mushroom show late show tonight giving
the guitar away tomorrow night
Monday night in Vegas but most
importantly check out the hey man
podcast wherever you get your podcast
the podcast is a lot of this I'm gonna
from here on out I'm gonna put the link
on there
yeah oh yeah we didn't do any joining us
today no
we will be in Arizona for New Year's
like always
um but we love you guys thanks for
joining us thank you thank you thank you
Tampa if you're in town we'll see you
guys tonight or tomorrow and
if you're not in Tampa we'll see you in
a city near you
this year yeah that's right Casey
absolutely loved Australia we'll be back
yeah we'll see you guys Amanda Nashville
on August 6th
there you go you know I get caught up in
these comments and I can just then I
just end up staying on the yeah I'm
gonna end it for him because he won't do
it thank you guys we love you we'll see
you see you soon later Tampa later